it's time to Deck the Halls with those
ugly holiday sweaters and you can do
that at one of the best clubs in town
the Legacy Club at the Circa and here to
tell us all about their upcoming ugly
sweater party from the Legacy Club is
lead bartender Ryan Clark welcome back
thank you so much for having me so good
to have you I see that you're wearing
the appropriate attire it's not that
ugly though I'll be honest it's kind of
cute this is my fun Santa sweater so
super cute now tell us about this party
that you guys are having so coming up on
uh next Friday not this Friday but the
next the 16th we're gonna have our ugly
sweater party uh eight to ten and it's
going to be a really good time and do
you just kind of wear the ugly sweater
and and you're are you guys going to
have contests for like the worst one
well I don't know if it's gonna be the
worst or the best we're gonna have some
kind of contest uh and actually we
brought in a bottle we have some
different Barrel picks some private
barrels that we have at Legacy club uh
Blanton's is a very popular one so we're
going to give that away to one of the
sweater wearers oh very fancy and of
course you're going to have like
Christmas cookies some decorating stuff
like that too you if you've never been
to Legacy club before I was actually
just there on Saturday not gonna lie it
is such a fun place and the views I mean
you can't see views like that anywhere
in Las Vegas I think there's some of the
best in the city for sure absolutely
well let's talk about one of the custom
cocktails that you're going to be making
for the big party and that you could
probably get anytime at Legacy club
right we can make a version of this
pretty much anytime but yeah we wanted
to make a couple cocktails we're gonna
have a punch that night okay we're gonna
have a couple signature cocktails this
is one of them and what is it called
this one's called Sweater Weather
Sweater Weather oh I already like this
okay what do we got here so this is
going to be our take on an old-fashioned
a nice fall of rendition so we're gonna
have your standard stuff bitters some
sugar and definitely gonna have to have
some whiskey in there okay whiskey has
always been like one of those things
where I just I'm like uh I'm unsure of
it so I'm hoping you can change my mind
you're gonna love this one okay okay so
we've already got our Bitters and our
mixing glass we're going to stir this
one up okay now let's add some of the uh
the simple syrup we've got a thigh spice
version okay we're gonna put half an
ounce in so that's halfway on the [ __ ]
I'm going to make one and you're going
to make one and then we're gonna have a
chair as a dance oh that's perfect so
right into our mixing glass
um half of it you said yep just on the
small side there uh
uh you're a natural light that's perfect
oh my gosh I already feel like a pro
okay all right so we've got that we've
got our bitters in the glass we're going
to need our bourbon we're using larceny
okay this week on this guy do we have to
measure that one we probably should
measure it's always a good idea to
measure your cocktails uh we're gonna
use two ounces so on the tall side of
this [ __ ] okay we're gonna go all the
way to the top whoa and right into our
glass okay oh man all right let's see
can I could I make it as a bartender
absolutely I've seen you pour before
right in the glass okay all right so
we're gonna put that to the side we need
to stir this up get it nice and cold so
we've got our spoon and just give that a
nice stir
you're so professional all we're trying
to do is get it nice and cold which I
think we've done okay so we need to get
that in our glass we're going to grab
our strainer put that right on top
uh-huh and we're gonna pour we've got a
glass there for you ready to go we got
the large format clear ice cube right on
top oh my goodness get all that nice
liquid in there got it all in there
awesome now we need a garnish for this
which is our orange peel and then I put
the glass down because we're going to
squeeze the juices out of this uh Orange
Peel right over top of our drink squeeze
it right in maybe a little twist
wipe the edges
beautiful this is why you're the lead
and that's going to be our garnish and
we're going to put that right in there
okay
and now we've got Sweater Weather
cocktails ready to go all right let's
give it a test does can you change my
mind on the whiskey
I hope so
mine changed mine changed I love it and
you can order this sweater weather at
the big sweater ugly sweater party 100.
definitely got to check it out it sounds
like a lot of fun I'll be there for sure
all right sounds good all right we'll
see send it over to you